der feind ist das virus sagt die
verfassungsministerien österreichs
karoline edtstadler auf der gemeinsamen
pressekonferenz mit dem
gesundheitsminister wolfgang möglich
stein das war ja wenn man so will ein
zwischenbericht österreich ist ja auf
dem weg zur impfpflicht sie soll ab
februar eingeführt werden und wird jetzt
sukzessive auf den parlamentarischen weg
geschickt professor emanuel richter hat
sich diese pressekonferenz hier auch
angehört herr professor richter könnte
etwas von dem was wir jetzt gehört haben
aus diesem prozess der einführung der
impfpflicht so etwas wie eine blaupause
für die diskussion in deutschland werden
welchen eindruck haben sie
ja also mein erster eindruck wäre der
teufel steckt im detail denn es hat sich
ja gezeigt dass tatsächlich ganz ganz
viele überlegungen geben muss das eine
ist zum beispiel ab wann also ab welchem
alter dann natürlich die frage wie
sanktioniert man das heißt also welche
art von strafe verhängt man wie hoch wie
oft welche art von konsequenzen hat die
städte weit weigerung also was muss man
dann tun und dann auch noch mal zum
beispiel fand ich sehr interessant und
wichtig auch der hinweis auf die
europäische menschenrechtskonvention
die ja
deutschland und österreich auch
unternehmen für den anderen
unterzeichnet haben und da der
sogenannte artikel 8 der ja die personen
und familien freizügigkeit regelt also
die freiheitsrechte und dann aber auch
gleichzeitig einschränkungen erwähnt und
erwägt unter bestimmten bedingungen das
heißt also man hat auch schon noch eine
einen rechtlichen rahmen den man
sorgfältig prüfen muss nicht nur die
nationalen verfassungen sondern auch die
europäische gesetzgebung also wie gesagt
der teufel steckt im detail ja auf der
anderen seite ist es ja so herr
professor richter wir gehen demnächst
ins dritte ja dieser pandemie mit
weitreichenden einschränkungen für unser
leben also die
sozialpsychologischen folgen zum
beispiel des ganzen sind ja noch gar
nicht richtig erforscht werden aber
vermutlich weitreichend sein was hindert
denn vor dem hintergrund dieser
entwicklung und dieser situation die
politik daran zu sagen wir haben es
versucht
es haben sich nicht mal 70 prozent bis
jetzt in deutschland impfen lassen jetzt
kann nur noch die impfpflicht uns aus
dieser sondersituation herausbringen
ja also wobei man sagen muss es hätte ja
vielleicht ein
dringenderes und dringlichere
appellativen charakter genügt das heißt
also aufforderung anreizsysteme schaffen
sich impfen zu lassen das hat man auch
ein bisschen schleifen lassen auch vor
dem hintergrund ja zunächst einmal dann
wieder sinken der infektionszahlen da
hat man so ein bisschen ja versäumt
genau das zu tun insofern denke ich ist
das jetzt so ein bisschen die
notmaßnahme darauf aber klar ist
natürlich dass man
jetzt eigentlich um diese impfpflicht
scheinbar nicht mehr herumkommt um eben
wirklich noch die letzten zögerer zu
irgendeiner in irgendeiner weise zu
drängenden also das heißt überall ein
überreden überredungskünste auf
verlangen nicht geschafft aber es bleibt
nach wie vor ein
verfassungsrechtlich und auch politisch
umstrittenes mittel denn einerseits
wünscht sich die bevölkerung von der
politik ja immer
reaktionen also tut was regelt dieses
problem andererseits wünscht man sich
nicht zuviel einschränkung und
hineinregieren die private lebensführung
und diesen diese konflikte muss die
politiker austariert ja man da
vielleicht nicht vergessen zu erwähnen
dass es durchaus auch immer noch
politische kreise gibt die ein interesse
haben daran dass die spaltung die es
vielleicht gibt zwischen menschen die
sich impfen lassen wollen und das
befürworten und denen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen die diese spaltung
weiter vorantreiben und versuchen
politisch kapital daraus zu ziehen der
professor richter wir stehen ja an
diesem dienstag vor der konferenz um 13
uhr der schaltkonferenz von bund und
ländern das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
die maßnahmen der bundesländer
für verfassungsgemäß
er hat also die klagen sind sozusagen
abgewiesen worden inwiefern ändert es
jetzt für die politisch verantwortlichen
für die handelnden den spielraum ist der
spielraum jetzt für maßnahmen wie
beispielsweise
verschärfung der maßnahmen die
beispielsweise von kanzleramtsminister
brown gefordert wird aber auch von
winfried kretschmann den wir mutmaßlich
gleich aus stuttgart hören werden ist
der spielraum jetzt weiter geworden
ich würde sagen ja also es ist muss
natürlich immer und das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
urteil mehrfach hervorgehoben die
verhältnismäßigkeit gewahrt werden ja
also die abwägung von einschränkungen
gegenüber demjenigen was man dann
erreicht damit das bezieht sich auf den
grundrechts teil unseres grundgesetzes
aber andererseits ist natürlich klar
geworden der staat ist verpflichtet zu
handeln um eben ein solches pandemie
geschehen eine solche gesundheitliche
bedrohung einzuschränken also er kann
nicht einfach sagen ihnen dort unter
hinweis auf grundrechtsschutz
freizügigkeit usw unternehmen wir gar
nichts also insofern ist die der auf die
aufforderung an die politik ergangen
handelt tut was weckt aber alle
maßnahmen sorgfältig ab aber ihr seid in
dem was ihre ziele angetan habt
rechtlich abgesichert und vermutlich
werdet ihr auch abgesichert sein das ist
jetzt eben die frage die natürlich noch
geprüft werden muss wenn ihr eine
impfpflicht einführt ja man darf
gespannt sein wie das dann heute über
die bühne gehen wird mit welchen
maßnahmen professor immer neue richter
war das ganz herzlichen dank für diese
analysen nach berlin